[Musique]
J'en veux
un, tu n'en as pas
un,
lâche-le 911, as-tu une urgence ? J'ai une
fille de 16 ans, elle n'est pas à
la maison, elle n'est pas allée
travailler, j'ai peur de la
mort, qu'est-ce qu'elle est ?  nom Tyler
nie
[Musique]
rentre à la maison dès que tu peux bébé nous l'
aimons bébé nous voulons qu'elle rentre à
la maison tu es si belle c'est une
Barbie binaa fais une danse virevoltante pour
moi deux semaines plus tard j'étais sûr qu'elle ne reviendrait pas
et je  c'était vrai, on pouvait juste le sentir
Skyler avait quitté le travail Rachel
et Sheila ils passaient en voiture, ils avaient dit
à la police plus tard qu'ils étaient allés avec
Skyler pour fumer du pod alors Skyler se faufile,
elle monte dans une voiture avec Rachel et
Sheila et ils partent  en Pennsylvanie,
ils sont à une voie, ils sont
entourés de Woods
quand ils sont arrivés là-bas, ils ont dit qu'ils avaient
oublié un briquet, ils ont dit à Skylar de
retourner à la voiture pour prendre un
briquet quand Skyler s'est retourné, c'est
quand ils l'ont attaquée,
ils  l'ont poignardée en comptant jusqu'à
trois 1 2 3 et ils ont commencé à la poignarder,
la question qu'elle lui a posée les derniers
mots qu'elle a prononcés étaient pourquoi parce qu'elle
ne savait vraiment pas pourquoi ils essayaient
de la tuer pourquoi ils l'avaient tuée
[Musique]
dans  depuis que je suis ici, soit
plus de 9 ans, c'est la plus grande
histoire que nous ayons
[Musique] [
Musique]
a eu
[Musique]
essentiellement pour supprimer et assassiner d'autres
personnes
[Musique]
Je ne sais pas, je pense  il doit probablement y
avoir un moment de prise de conscience de la
gravité de tout quand vous êtes
dans cette situation, comme Rachel et Sheila, c'est
vraiment sérieux maintenant,
je suis au tribunal, je suis menotté, je suis dans une
orange
combinaison
[Musique]
en ce moment tu peux rester assis si
tu veux mon
père je suis vraiment
désolé je ne sais pas s'il y a une bonne
façon de présenter ces
excuses pas même des mots pour décrire la
culpabilité et les remords mais je ressens chaque jour que je  J'ai
eu peur et j'ai été pris dans quelque chose
que je ne voulais pas faire. Je n'ai jamais
réalisé la gravité de mes
actes. Cela a blessé la famille de ma nièce et
ceux qui aiment Skyler. J'ai blessé mes parents, j'ai fait honte à
ma famille et j'ai blessé mon Seigneur et
Sauveur Jésus-Christ.  apportez à
nouveau la paix éternelle à Schar dans toute la nouvelle famille. Je suis vraiment désolé et je prie
chaque jour pour
le pardon, cela se produit réellement,
nous avons été attrapés, ils savent ce que nous avons fait, tout le
monde nous déteste maintenant. Rachel aurait
également dû assassiner ma fille au complet.
fille de sang ne serait pas là où elle
était sans Rachel et elle peut
prendre ses excuses et tout le reste sur quoi
s'asseoir parce que c'est à peu près ce qu'ils
valent. Rachel était une fille troublée, elle
devait être la fille parfaite pour un
mère exigeante, elle était une adepte, elle
aimait les gens, je pense qu'elle manquait
beaucoup
d'assurance du côté opposé. Sheila semblait
n'avoir aucun sentiment de remords pour tout ce qu'elle
avait fait, ses actions
lui semblaient tout à fait acceptables, mais pour
les spectateurs, Sheila n'était pas tellement très
pas contrôlant mais manipulateur, je ne
sais pas, elle pouvait juste vous enfermer
dans ce qu'elle voulait faire, elle
avait un moyen de vous faire accepter de faire
ce qu'elle voulait
faire, je m'appelle Shai Ammons, je viens de
Morgantown West  Virginia et moi sommes la
meilleure
amie de Skyler. J'ai rencontré Skyler par l'intermédiaire de Sheila.
En fait, ils étaient de très bons amis
et Sheila et moi avions une bonne relation. La
famille de Sheila emmenait Skyler
partout avec eux. Skyler serait
avec Sheila chaque week-end, ils étaient une
famille comme ils l'étaient.  à peu près mes
sœurs, elles étaient ensemble tout le
temps,
vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fre Je m'appelle Dalen Barry et je suis l'auteur
de Pretty Little Killers, le livre sur
le ciel
Meurtre policier Sheila et Skyler sont devenus amis
en CE2, ils  est allé au lycée
à l'université en même temps que
Rachel Cha a arrêté d'aller à
l'école catholique et a été transférée à l'
université. Ils se sont rencontrés ensemble dans une classe et
sont devenus
amis [musique] Sheila et Rachel avaient de l'argent
Sheila avait une voiture et Skyler avait cette
personnalité extravertie  cela a fait que tout le monde
l'aimait et donc ils ont chacun apporté
quelque chose à la table de l'Amitié
pour ainsi
dire, je m'appelle Rodney Lamp. Je suis
producteur exécutif ici à WB TV, je suis une
chaîne d'information locale pour le centre de la
Virginie occidentale. Star City est une petite
municipalité à côté de  Morgantown
Virginie-Occidentale, c'est une ville universitaire. Je pense que la
population totale, en comptant les étudiants,
est peut-être de 60 000 quand ils y sont et d'
environ 30 000 quand ils n'y sont pas. C'est juste
une petite
ville. La ville étoile est très petite, très petite,
c'est comme une banlieue de Morgan Town.  il y a
une force de police qui ne compte que quelques
agents il n'y a que quelques
entreprises c'est une communauté calme et tranquille
on a l'impression que quand
on y est, ce serait un bon endroit pour
élever une
famille euh
[Musique]
ouais ok je m'appelle Mary, ma nièce  Je suis la
mère de Skyler, je travaille dans
les hôpitaux universitaires de Virginie occidentale à Morgantown, en
Virginie occidentale, lorsque j'ai découvert que j'étais enceinte
de Skyler, ce fut une
surprise, je ne peux pas dire que c'était un
sentiment formidable. J'étais inquiète, je ne savais pas si je
serais une bonne mère.  Je n'ai jamais vraiment
eu envie d'avoir des enfants mais je dois
dire qu'après l'avoir eu, tu sais, quand une
mère regarde son enfant, le monde entier
change ouais c'était
génial hé
gor tu es magnifique
bébé tu es une fille c'est vrai, elle
n'est pas  plus un bébé, c'est une petite fille,
dit-elle, tu es vraiment
ouais. Skyler était très ambitieuse,
turbulente, car la plupart des enfants avaient plus d'énergie qu'elle ne
savait quoi faire avec un deux
trois trois sauts, tu
souris, tu es un enfant fou
[Musique], je
m'appelle Dave  Depuis que je suis le père de Skyler,
je travaille chez
Walmart et j'ai 58 ans, il ne doit pas
venir
ici. Mary travaillait pendant la journée et je
la surveillais à la maison donc nous
jouions au goûter et elle était serveuse.
J'étais une cliente.  je payais avec de la fausse monnaie
et elle remplissait ma petite tasse et je la
buvais finalement Mary rentrait du
travail et elle disait qu'est-ce que vous
faites, alors qu'est-ce que vous buvez Dave
et j'ai dit juste l'eau et elle a dit que
vous réalisez Kyler  Je ne peux pas atteindre le
robinet à droite et j'ai
dit ouais, j'ai dit scyler, où as-tu
trouvé cette eau et elle m'a emmené à la
salle de bain et m'a montré les toilettes et a
dit là-
dedans, j'ai dit oh mon
Dieu maintenant c'est hilarant mais ce
n'était pas le cas  très
[Musique]
drôle elle était une artiste en herbe une
musicienne en herbe tout ce qui pouvait l'occuper l'
esprit ou elle a vu à la télé elle allait le
faire elle voulait être serveuse elle
voulait être avocate une esthéticienne une
caissière Walmart tout ça  des choses en
même temps, un
enseignant plus tard, en grandissant et
elle voulait en fait devenir
avocate pénaliste, il fume, c'est pour
les idiots, je suis un idiot
alors oh, elle avait l'habitude de demander à son père et je pense que
je serais un bon avocat  et
elle était très
argumentative donc j'étais comme si tu serais un
fantastique
avocat [Musique], nous avons tous commencé à passer
des soirées pyjama et à nous faufiler vers 14 heures. Je
dirais
[Musique] que j'en
veux
un, tu n'en as pas un,
Dieu, je suis  comme oh mon Dieu, tu as
des [ __ ] dans ton [ __ ] de frigo mais
allons-
y, nous sortirions en douce, nous boirions et nous
fumerions honnêtement de la marijuana et
prendrions beaucoup de photos et nous
amuserions beaucoup, puis nous reviendrions avant que ses
parents ne se réveillent  elle avait été
surprise en train de sortir furtivement avant qu'à un moment donné la
police ne l'ait ramenée à la maison, ils avaient
attrapé les filles et quelques gars les avaient rejoints en
traversant la ville et c'était un
couvre-feu. Dave et Mary nie savaient que
Skyler s'était faufilée hors de sa chambre plusieurs
fois auparavant peut-être  ils étaient un peu
moins surveillés qu'ils n'auraient dû l'être,
sachant qu'ils avaient une
fille adolescente qui était encline à faire ça. La
mère de Sheila Eddie, Tara, était très
très indulgente, elle voulait être la
maman cool alors elle a laissé sa fille fumer de l'herbe
à une soirée.  garçons quand elle était très
jeune Le père de Sheila avait
des problèmes de toxicomanie sur les deux faces de la médaille était la
mère de Rachel Patricia
montrer certains étudiants m'ont dit qu'elle était
violente certains de ses amis adultes ont dit
qu'elle était violente envers
Rachel Patricia cha avait bu
[Musique  ]
problème Skyler avait
également une vie familiale très dysfonctionnelle même si ses parents
l'aimaient beaucoup et ne la
maltraitaient pas en soi, mais ils avaient leurs
propres problèmes même si l'un de ces
problèmes était l'incapacité de fournir un
foyer financièrement stable à Skyler et
donc  en conséquence, Skyler avait envie d'être
amie avec des gens qui avaient de l'argent et
qui pouvaient lui fournir certaines choses
qu'elle n'avait pas.
d'entre nous, elle le faisait à peu près
tous les soirs, euh en première année et
rentrait à la maison juste avant que sa mère ne se lève
pour le travail et elle la maintenait toujours
droite dans la moyenne parce qu'elle se souciait de l'
école, je ne sais pas comment elle a fait mais
elle l'a fait  Nous pensions souvent que sa
fuite était
terminée, mais vous savez, avec le recul, non, cela
n'était pas
terminé. Sheila et Skyler étaient en fait
très impliqués dans les médias sociaux, euh bien plus
que moi à l'époque et ils partageaient
tout ensemble, comme ils en parlaient
tout le temps.
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont littéralement partagé toute leur vie les
uns avec les autres donc
ils savaient tout les uns sur les autres donc
s'ils postaient quelque chose bien sûr ils
impliquent l'autre
[Musique]
le 21 août 2011 il y avait  cette
fête chez Skyler où
Sheila et
Skyler m'avaient raconté une fois
quand ils étaient tous les trois
chez la mère de Rachel et qu'ils
buvaient et Sheila et Rachel étaient
devenues intimes et Sky était
mal à l'aise mais ils ne voulaient pas la laisser
partir, nous ne connaissons pas les détails exacts de
ce qui s'est passé, mais il était assez évident
qu'ils ont eu une relation sexuelle cette
nuit-là. Sheila et Rachel et Skylar ont été
forcées d'observer cela et la raison pour laquelle
elle a été forcée et j'utilise ce mot est
parce que Rachel  maman était dans une autre
partie de la maison et ils ne voulaient pas
la réveiller parce que Rachel avait dit à
Sheila et Skylar que sa mère était
méchante et pouvait être violente et donc Skyler
ne voulait pas prendre de risque et elle les a vu
devenir sexuellement  actives
ensemble, elle était consciente qu'ils avaient un
lien étroit qu'elle n'avait pas et cela l'a
amenée à agir à leur égard.
Elle et Sheila ont ensuite commencé à se disputer et à se
battre sur les réseaux sociaux et elle a menacé de discuter
du fait qu'elle avait proféré une menace sur les réseaux sociaux.  Dans
les médias [musicaux], vous savez, les gens des petites villes parlent
et dans une petite ville, il y a des rumeurs, des rumeurs se produisent
si
quelque chose d'extraordinaire se produit,
les gens vont en parler. La
famille de Rachel était très religieuse
et très très stricte, donc si la famille de Rachel
la famille aurait découvert beaucoup de
choses qu'elle faisait à l'époque, cela
n'aurait pas été
bon
[Musique]
il est devenu évident qu'il y avait des
fissures dans la relation qui se
formait Skyler aimait Rachel Sheila aimait
Rachel Rachel aimait Sheila  ce type de
trio ne peut jamais être complètement réconcilié
parce que c'est un homme étrange, il y a
toujours une personne qui n'est pas aussi
égale que
[Musique]
d'autres
pour
Skyler étaient allés à la plage avec la
famille de Sheila et sur le chemin du retour
c'était  Il était évident qu'ils s'étaient
disputés, quelle que soit la cause de la
dispute et à ce moment-là, Sheila a
dit à
Rachel que nous devions la tuer. Je suis allé
traverser les sentiers ferroviaires en
criant en hurlant. J'ai passé des nuits dans les bois à
espionner cette maison parce qu'il a dit qu'elle l'était.  Je
suis allé à une fête là-bas et oui, nous avons
aussi fait notre travail de détective, faites-moi confiance
[Musique] [Musique]
Skyler a commencé à se faire mettre hors de
la relation, ils ont commencé à faire des choses
sans elle, comme si Sheila
appelait Rachel et planifiait quoi porter le
lendemain, mais ils  Je n'ai pas dit à
Skyler qu'ils avaient commencé à planifier
des choses ensemble et Skyler a été laissée de côté
et quand elle a découvert qu'elle était bouleversée à
ce moment-là, nous n'avons pas
vraiment surveillé ses pages de médias sociaux,
mais vous savez, il y avait plusieurs messages
qu'elle avait publiés à ce sujet.  a parlé de la raison pour laquelle les
filles lui faisaient des choses comme elles la
traitaient
[Musique]
Je pense vraiment que tu sais que Skyler voulait
appartenir, elle avait deux amis, ils
avaient déjà fait des choses ensemble, ils
appréciaient la compagnie de l'autre, je pense qu'elle
voulait juste en faire partie  de quelque chose,
vous, un groupe que vous connaissez, amusez-vous avec
quelqu'un pour faire des choses
[Musique],
les jours qui ont précédé le meurtre
étaient très stressants et il n'y avait
rien d'autre que des bagarres
[Musique]
et puis tout d'un coup, Skyler reçoit
ce message texte  apparemment en disant hé,
allons faire la fête, puis ils viennent la chercher
sur le parking de son
immeuble et elle
disparaît
911 as-tu une urgence J'ai une
fille de 16 ans apparemment, elle
s'est faufilée hors de sa chambre hier soir et elle
n'a pas  on ne l'a pas vue depuis qu'elle n'est pas à
la maison, elle n'est pas allée travailler, aucun de ses
amis ne peut la joindre, je ne
la trouve pas, je suis
mort de peur, c'était un
matin normal ce jour-là, Skyler devait travailler chez
elle.  travail à temps partiel mais ce jour-là je rentrais
à la maison et d'habitude Skyler était
prête j'ai frappé à sa porte qui était
verrouillée j'ai dit chérie c'est papa il est temps
d'aller travailler pas de réponse alors j'ai crié très
fort
[Musique]
Skyler pas de réponse  alors j'ai ouvert la porte et
son lit n'avait pas été dormi et la
fenêtre de la chambre était fissurée à ce
moment-là, alors j'ai commencé à m'inquiéter alors j'ai
appelé Mary immédiatement, elle m'a dit d'appeler
Sheila qui était censée être la
meilleure amie de Skyler alors je l'ai appelée et  J'ai dit
hé, as-tu vu Skyler, a-t-elle dit Nous nous sommes
faufilés hier soir et j'ai dit à quand remonte
la dernière fois que tu lui as parlé, elle a dit
hier soir vers minuit et euh ensuite nous avons eu
des images du propriétaire qui est
descendu et nous a montré les
caméras et a vu  Skyler est monté dans une
voiture à ce moment-là, nous ne pouvions pas dire à qui
appartenait la voiture. Le
supposé meilleur ami de Skyler. Je
les appelle un morceau de merde un et un morceau de merde
deux parce que c'est exactement ce qu'ils sont, une
merde quand ils se tenaient là
quand nous regardions.  à la vidéo, elle
savait très bien que c'était sa voiture mais bien
sûr, elle
n'a rien dit
nous ne savons pas
où elle est, c'est la dernière fois que nous l'avons vue,
sa supposée meilleure amie avait dit quand
ils sont sortis en douce ce soir-là, ils
l'avaient déposée dans la rue parce
qu'elle ne voulait pas qu'ils la déposent à la
maison, elle l'a fait.  Je ne veux pas qu'on se réveille et qu'on
lui découvre qu'elle s'est encore faufilée
lundi, toute la ville
était au courant de ce qui s'était
passé. Je suis allé sur les réseaux sociaux et certaines
personnes détestent les réseaux sociaux, on vous a dit que
j'adore, il y avait de l'herbe partout.  si vite que
tout le monde essayait d'aider,
ils étaient derrière
[Musique]
nous Je suis allé à Saberton à travers les
sentiers jaunes et en criant J'ai passé
des nuits dans les bois à espionner cette maison
parce qu'il a dit qu'elle allait à une fête
là-bas et ouais  nous avons aussi fait notre travail de détective,
croyez-moi, Sheila, un flic, et moi étions montés
dans la voiture de police et Sheila nous a emmenés dans
ce supposé voyage qu'ils avaient fait et
qui se trouvait juste autour de Star City, ce
n'était pas un très long trajet et a dit que
c'est tout ce qu'ils avaient fait cette nuit-là
et elle l'a déposée Sheila était
impliquée dans l'enquête comme si elle
nous aidait à chercher Skyler tout le
temps et agissait comme si elle savait
[Musique]
rien,
ils ont continué à aller à l'école comme si de
rien n'était  Je suis allée au bal même
ouais, elle n'avait pas agi bizarrement du tout, elle était
triste et elle a pleuré comme si elle lui manquait,
Skyler, elle a parlé de Skyler, elle
semblait vraiment se soucier que Skyler soit
partie en regardant certains des messages qu'elle a
publiés tout au long de tout ce Skyler.  rentre
à la maison Skyler tu nous manques quand vas-tu
rentrer à la maison Skyler nous devons trouver
[Musique]
Skyler Sheila avait des
tendances psychopathiques mais ce n'est pas facile de dire qu'elle
était une psychopathe parce que tous les adolescents
peuvent avoir ces
tendances,
préférez-vous étouffer ou vous faire
tirer dessus  se faire tirer dessus, cela dépend du
vainqueur, préféreriez-vous que dans la balle dans la tête,
il n'y ait aucune souffrance mangée par
une fourmi ou étouffée
étouffée noyée ou étouffée étouffante
c'est presque la même chose que je
sais mais ce
n'est pas bien donc c'est l'histoire de la fosse de Sheila
vous savez, j'ai lu des récits d'
étudiants qui ont entendu Rachel et Sheila
parler à l'avance de ce qu'ils
prévoyaient de
faire. Cela a commencé comme une blague en
cours de sciences quand ils étaient en
deuxième année, ils recherchaient comment se
débarrasser des
corps [Musique] à  à un moment donné, les forces de l'ordre
ont commencé à changer d'avis sur ces
deux filles parce que ce sont elles qui l'
ont vue pour la dernière fois, elles ont dit
que Chris de la police d'État était venu
me voir un jour, il a dit Dave, est-ce que tu
crois tout ce que dit le supposé ami de Skyler
toi, j'ai dit bien sûr que je le
fais, pourquoi ne le ferais-je pas, a-t-il dit, puis-je vous montrer
quelque chose ici, c'est là où se trouve son téléphone portable,
elle envoie un ping à cette tour à 40 miles de
distance, pourquoi est-ce arrivé, a dit qu'elle était à
la maison, cela n'arriverait pas si  elle était à
la maison, la police savait qu'ils en savaient plus
parce qu'ils rataient
les tests de détection, en particulier la femme de 80 ans, elle en a
raté deux,
la seule chose qu'elle avait bien compris, c'était
son
nom. Sheila ne réussissait pas le test ouais
ouais et Rachel l'était  celle qui a sauté
de la voiture en mouvement pour éviter de passer
le test
[Musique]
ouais Rachel était définitivement la plus faible des
deux, elle n'est pas le cerveau
derrière ce qui se passe
[Musique]
tu es fou, tant que
Sheila peut l'être  près d'elle tout au long de l'
année scolaire, je pense qu'ils ont plutôt bien réussi,
elle l'a en quelque sorte gardée sous contrôle et s'est
assurée qu'elle ne disait rien, s'est
assurée qu'elle ne s'est pas cassée, mais ensuite,
une fois les vacances de Noël arrivées, ils
étaient loin l'un de l'autre.  autre Mary
parlait à Rachel un soir sur l'
ordinateur, envoyant des SMS dans les deux sens. Rachel
m'avait demandé si
elle et sa mère pouvaient faire quelque chose pour
nous. J'ai dit que nous devions juste la mettre au
repos, la laisser se reposer
[Musique]
paix et c'est un ou deux jours après
cette
conversation que Rachel s'est retrouvée dans le
métal. Son internement à l'hôpital psychiatrique
a commencé par une bagarre entre elle et
sa
mère. J'ai un problème avec une de
mes filles de 16 ans.  je ne peux
plus la contrôler, [ __ ], elle
crie, elle court dans le
quartier, donne-moi le
téléphone, non, c'est fini, mon mari
a retourné le
conteneur s'il te plaît
[Musique]
dépêche-toi, elle a été emmenée à l'hôpital Chest R toss
où elle est restée plusieurs
jours.  elle ne peut pas continuer à cacher
ce qui se passe
[Musique]
Rachel raconte enfin à un avocat ce qui
s'est passé, elle admet enfin ce qu'ils ont
fait, ils ont tué
Skyler Sheila Skyler et Rachel avaient
prévu de s'enfuir alors Sheila et
Rachel ont choisi Sky  elle se lève, elle se faufile
par la fenêtre comme nous l'avons toujours fait, euh, elle a
couru vers la
voiture [Musique] [Musique] ils montent en
Pennsylvanie, je pense que c'est à environ 30
miles de Morgant Town, c'est là qu'ils
l'emmènent quand ils sont sortis là-bas  ils ont dit
qu'ils avaient oublié le
briquet alors ils ont dit à Skyler de retourner
à la voiture pour prendre un
briquet ils ont une sorte de signal
ils ont une sorte d'avidité d'AG au
moment où ils vont faire
ça, ils l'ont poignardée sur le compte de
trois 1 2 3 et ils ont commencé à la poignarder,
elle essaie de s'enfuir, elle essaie de se
défendre, elle finit par attraper le
couteau de Rachel et la poignarder à
la
jambe,
elle est trop faible à ce moment-là, alors ils continuent de
la poignarder dans le dos et partout où
ils l'ont poignardée.  Jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
morte, ils l'ont poignardée au cou plus de
50 fois et ils ont essayé de creuser un trou pour créer une
barrière mais le sol était trop
dur. Ils avaient une pelle avec eux. Ils ont
essayé de creuser un trou mais ils n'y sont pas parvenus.
Ils ont simplement décidé de le faire.  ils ont couvert son corps
avec des branches et d'autres
choses, puis ils
l'ont laissée là, ils ont compté jusqu'à
trois, c'était leur plan, puis ils
l'ont tuée mercredi. Rachel Cha, 16 ans,
a plaidé coupable de meurtre au deuxième degré.
en cours
contre un deuxième mineur en détention
également, tout est dit à la radio, un autre
mineur avait été arrêté et à ce
moment-là, je savais que c'était Sheila. J'ai essayé
de contacter Sheila, bien sûr, aucune réponse, alors j'ai
appelé la mère de Mary um Skyler et
lui ai demandé si quoi  J'avais entendu dire que c'était vrai
et si l'autre mineur était Sheila et
elle a dit oui, c'était ces deux
[ __ ] qui avaient leur place dans la
prison [Musique], alors je l'ai emmené là où c'était arrivé
et j'ai dit que c'était juste là, eh bien, ils
ont sorti les chiens cadabra  ils ont pris,
vous savez, tout ce qu'ils pouvaient trouver, il y
a un énorme chêne juste sur le
site de Scot, un des chiens Kadab
s'est arrêté et a regardé droit vers le haut et son
collier GPS est
tombé juste au-dessus de
Skyler, c'est ainsi qu'ils l'ont trouvée et
à ce moment-là  elle était là-bas depuis 6
mois, elle s'est détériorée, tu sais, elle
n'était que des os, juste
des os. J'étais
sous le choc, j'étais dévasté, j'étais
durement
fauché, mon seul meilleur ami avait déjà
été tué et nous avions déjà dû
faire face à cela et maintenant mon  un autre meilleur
ami est arrêté pour meurtre et je
suis avec cette fille quotidiennement depuis
des années. Comment peux-tu, comment quelqu'un peut-il
te cacher ça alors que tu passes autant de
temps avec eux, tu as cet
ami proche qui est un de
tes amis depuis
des années, tu tues cette personne et tu quittes
son
corps et tu le dissimules tu mens à
ce sujet pendant 6 mois tu publies ces choses sur les
réseaux sociaux en faisant semblant de
t'inquiéter de son
bien-être tu participes même aux
efforts de recherche pour la retrouver toi  passer du temps avec
la famille et leur apporter
un certain réconfort pendant tout cela.
Comment diable deux adolescentes pourraient-elles
tuer leur amie comme ça, cela
n'a aucun sens,
nous le prenons un jour à la fois, chaque jour.
réveillez-vous, nous fonctionnons ouais, nous
fonctionnons toujours parce que vous devez le faire, vous ne pouvez pas vous
rouler en boule et mourir, vous devez
continuer et la vie vous dit que vous
ne pouvez pas arrêter de vivre, beaucoup de gens font
beaucoup de  les gens que vous connaissez entrent dans une maison
quelque part et ils s'arrêtent et ils se
figent et ce n'est pas nous, nous ne pouvons pas faire
ça
[Musique]
Je n'arrive toujours pas à croire que le meurtre
a eu lieu Je n'arrive toujours pas à croire que d'un
simple coup de bouton  ma vie d'adolescent s'est
complètement transformée en un film à vie,
en gros, j'ai travaillé avec quelques médecins
pour surmonter cela, alors j'essaie de ne plus
me laisser abattre, donc les seuls
jours où j'ai du mal sont les
jours où  y a-t-il des dates d'anniversaire
[Musique]
a